und wir machen weiter mit einer schönen
geschichte denn bild ist im mittelmeer
unterwegs und testet die erste
kreuzfahrt mit landgang klingt jetzt
nicht sonderlich spannend aber wegen den
corona maßnahmen mussten bisher alle
passagiere immer an bord bleiben jetzt
also die premiere
und bevor wir darüber sprechen schauen
uns doch ganz kurz an wie das leben auf
dem schiff so aussieht
es ist die tour der hoffnung die tui
mein schiff startet nach griechenland
und zum ersten mal dürfen landausflüge
gemacht werden dazu dass es auch die
erste reise wo man wieder
überdurchschnittliche kapazität erlaubt
es 700 menschen sind an bord normal
passend 2500 hier auf das
kreuzfahrtschiff der tui wir wollten den
test machen und haben alles ausprobiert
was möglich ist wie kann man seinen
urlaub hier auf dem schiff verbringen
und 1 war eben immer dabei
diese maske aber es kann trotzdem spaß
machen sehen sie selbst an deck viel
platz die sportkurse übersichtlich viele
geschäfte geschlossen
trotzdem sind die passagiere der mein
schiff sechs glücklich endlich wieder
kreuzfahrt urlaub gefreut
das einfach nicht ohne die kreuzfahrt
pause die ich hatte waren
die sechs monate
und da wir wirklich dafür brennen wieder
aufs meer hinaus zu gehen was man schon
sagen die neuen strecken einfach das
erste rein auf das meer zu schauen und
dafür nimmt man noch einige
einschränkungen in kauf im restaurant
zum beispiel muss man sich die hände
waschen und desinfizieren
das essen wird auf dem teller
angerichtet und es gilt masken pflicht
und auch in den kabinen wird nichts dem
zufall überlassen
der wichtigste punkt da ist das für
einer nebelmaschine einsetzen das heißt
jede einzelne kabine die belegtes oder
bewegt wird oder belegt war wird mit der
nähmaschine maschine am wechsel tag
einmal durch folgt nennt sich das in
unserer sprache sei es das wird ein
nebel erzeugt aus einem
desinfektionsmittel in dem fall oxidiert
das wird in der kompletten kabine und im
bad versprüht danach wird die kabine zu
gemacht für eine halbe stunde damit sich
der nebel legen kann damit auch nichts
für die gäste passieren kann und dass
allen grund liegt auch im boot spital
wurde aufgestockt zwei ärzte und drei
krankenschwestern stehen jederzeit
bereit
sie haben die intensivstation wir können
einen patienten mit herzinfarkt
behandelt medikamentes wir können
beatmen und wir können natürlich auch
andere krankheitsbilder entsprechend
behandeln sollte ein passagier corona
symptome aufweisen müssten die mediziner
übrigens im schutzanzug in die kabine
und einen abstrich nehmen nach einem
schnelltest im labor hätte der chirurg
innerhalb von 70 minuten das ergebnis
doch sowohl die besatzung und auch die
gäste hoffen dass es dazu nicht kommen
wird schließlich mussten sie vor
reiseantritt einen negativen corona test
vorweisen
und so fehlt den meisten passagieren auf
der mein schiff sechs eigentlich nur
eine sache die sonst auf kreuzfahrten
üblich geselligkeit
es ist alles getrennt wer mit seinem
partner aufs schiff geht bleibt auch die
ganze zeit mit seinem partner alleine
aber hauptsache kreuz hat man sieht
wieder länder
man sieht wieder das meer und das
personal gibt sich alle mühe diese
konzepte hier einzuhalten
und jetzt sprechen wir live wittke
franzke du bist am mittelmeer das den
ersten landgang getestet wie war's und
worauf muss die leute achten sehr genau
wir sehen gerade losgefahren geben und
sehen nicht nur jetzt
morgen seebad und wenn ich mit den
leuten hier sprechen die leute alle an
land planen alle dasselbe ereignis denn
es war das erste schiff wieder anlegen
im hafen
daraufhin sind wir dann auch die
akropolis begann dann hintermannschaft
15.000 menschen heute liefen da
lediglich 500 leute rum
das war unglaublich zu sehen
man konnte nochmals nach einem konter
alleine machen
unser guide hat gesagt das ist normal
unmöglich denn hier erst ins normale maß
und eben wir konkreter leben wenn man
die regeln wie wenn man von bord geht
nach machbar an
man muss einen meter abstand halten die
puppen den kleiner normal
vor einem jahr waren 50 leute in einem
bus des 18
und eben das ist ganz ganz wichtig man
darf sich nicht von der probe entfernt
sich von der gruppe entfernt nimmt schon
in meinem schlitten nicht mehr mit da
muss man schon selber aus und sehen zum
beispiel die heute nach harte regeln
aber verständlich wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter ist das der einzige landgang oder
ist noch mehr geplant seien auf korfu
sind aber ebenso wichtiges im tui die
verdient damit man nicht das große geld
aber sie wollen wir den tourismus jetzt
wieder losgeht und auch im hochsommer
trend machen wir haben den beitrag
bereits eine große tour strecke war vier
monate pause manche fahren
viermal im jahr und eben da war eine
durch strecke die gott sei dank jetzt
hoffentlich ändern hat aber eben mit
diesem knaller pascal transfer vielen
vielen dank und ich wünsche